Jake you become a bit of a folk hero
here this story kind of broke out after
Berkeley you know you live in the Bay
Area let me really quickly set this up
for people who haven't seen it Jake's
shield was there when the Berkeley
protest what protest riot broke out
after Milo and they were beating on some
poor innocent sap and Jake stepped in
let's roll the greek makes it he's not
Jewish he's Greek therefore so okay tell
us what happened did you actually some
report said you just started throwing
punches we cut to get them off the guy
what did you see and how did it come
about you know there was a big protest
like somewhere I guess right going on
you see was chaotic I was kind of but I
was kind of watching from the back to
the my girlfriend didn't want her to go
you know give me 80 bucks you know these
people Omar and I also see some guy just
running off getting chased by the mobs
of people with bats and sticks mass
chasing him down beating up you only see
a few people the thing there was it
hundreds of them there yeah I mean
they're chasing guys down everyone's
cheering them on be like get the Nazi
clearly you know I know that's probably
not really not saying no these people in
the left just gone insane or they attack
anyone that's a trump supporter so I run
in there and start fighting people off
you know throw a couple of punches
pushing people back I mean luckily
they're uh luckily it wasn't the
toughest guys with sticks yeah well it
could have been Jeff Monson in which
case you'd have problems these guys are
like I think the most hipster
neighborhood you can imagine these guys
like the face is covered and their
little skinny jeans and running around
like the little bats
they'll run in I throw a hit and then
jump back I felt like scared when you
throw are you sure you were not in a
real-life rendition of Double Dragon
because that's what I'm yeah
I have waited mininum they didn't even
take me down so that's what I tried to
eat using the situation you know many
coal punches which which a couple of
them back got hit a few times hook throw
the guy in the store and then just yeah
that was that that was a little bit
aftermath to be trying to like after I
walked out of the store you know these
guys yeah well I mean it really was a
scene I mean let me ask you this in your
estimation was this just some small
contingency because people were saying
it was a small group approach the
protest is largely peaceful and these
were disruptors you were there on the
ground and the rest of were cheering
them on like it was a good thing like it
was just it was it was a win out there
it was not a peaceful protest it was a
you know the peaceful protestors were
breaking it on it was disgrace and the
reports were largely peaceful so you
would say here it was not this was
absolutely no I mean I wanted to go back
there to try to help people but my
girlfriends would mean she's uh she went
in like I was telling her to go to the
car awaits a new shoots or mouthing off
and get be and I don't think she
realized these people would have no
problem beating her up yes you know
later in videos we saw what happened
it's uh it's terrible I feel guilty they
couldn't go back and try to help you
know I seen girls like post on Twitter
you know they just got a hospital with
broken ribs and husband's still in the
hospital and it's uh yeah it was a
disgraceful situation since I my
girlfriend relieved I tried getting the
perfect please to come back in with me
and they just they refused to yeah Wow
any reason as to why they did there's
like too much is going on just tell me
to just don't worry about it just won't
be safe I worry about the people they're
just getting beat up for no other
reasons in their their political views
yeah oh can we get up you get a push
back from this and I think from my I put
my liberal friends I think they need to
push back against this and some of them
are like this is not okay this is not
what our values represent this is not
who we are
stop doing this and I'm seeing mix like
my facebook some guys are saying this is
wrong other people are like trying to
justify the violence being like well
Milo is gonna do this he was gonna say
that running all these like big stories
and it's just uh you know fellow
liberals and moderates need to push back
and sees people I don't know what
they're doing is discussing and the fact
that no one jumped in to help and those
things that were that really bothered me
including them please I think the mayor
I'm told to stand down I don't like to
I'm big fan of please I don't like to go
out great a vigil offers officers but no
no go in there with me it's a shameful
yeah it really is well Jake we're glad
that you're getting some some heat for
this some good some good spotlight
attention and Jake Shields calm and on
Twitter at Jake Shields
ajj people go and show
you love them and hopefully next time we
see you we can actually see the punches
that's what I want to see yes if you
like this video subscribe by clicking
the button that says subscribe if you're
not aware of it now there's no way
you're learning the internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to Lata with credit calm /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than six dollars a month and
you get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand at mug oh I just when I feel
it I got a chill like on the inside